قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جالاند ان
اغلاق مضيق باب المندب ليس مشكله اسرائيل
وحدها بل هو تهديد للملاحه الدوليه وخلال
تفقده الرصيف الحربي في ميناء ايلات على
البحر الاحمر قال جالنت ان اسرائيل ستعرف
كيف تدافع عن
نفسها الخفش الخطر على حريه الملاحه بمذق
باب المندب لا يشكل تهديدا على حركه النقل
البحري الى اسرائيل فحس
ايضا على الملاحه الدوليه اشكر صديقي وزير
الدفاع الجنرال لويد اوستين لتوليه هذه
المهمه وقياده قوه المهمات المتعدده
الجنسيات التي تتمثل مهمتها في ضمان
الملاحه للجميع في مديق باب المندب اذا
استمروا في استفزازنا او حاولوا ضرب ايلات
بالصواريخ او وسائل اخرى فسنعرف ما يجب
القيام به نحن نستعد ومقاتلون جاهزون لاي
مهمه دوله اسرائيل من خلال القوات البحريه
والجويه ستعرف كيف تدافع عن
نفسها